Her years are really even four decades.
The gun people, as they're sometimes known,
the pro-gun activists, the gun fetishists.
The National Rifle Association, other groups,
they've been warning us.
They've been telling us we absolutely need
more guns.
We need more guns in more places.
We need guns everywhere because the government
could become tyrannical.
It's possible that someone might try to turn
the United States into a police state.
It could be a president who is a totalitarian
nightmare, who might do something like deploying
the military across the country.
And those exact same people have been silent,
as Donald Trump has said.
He doesn't care what governors say.
He'll send in the military if he wants to,
to suppress protests that are protected by
the First Amendment.
And in fact, as we saw the National Guard
and very militarized police units and riot
squads deployed to protests around the country,
which have been overwhelmingly peaceful.
The NRA and the gun people have said nothing.
We saw a riot squad take down Martin Guggi.
No, an unarmed 75 year old man knocked over
by police, hitting his head, bleeding from
his ear, spending nearly a week in the hospital.
And the president got involved to attack the
protester rather than the police who did this.
This is exactly what the NRA and others have
been warning us about.
And as Matt Cohen writes for Mother Jones,
all of those people, all of those groups have
been absolutely silent.
Wayne LaPierre from the NRA wrote 25 years
ago that it's possible that, quote, jackbooted
government thugs would get more power to take
away our constitutional rights, destroy our
property, even injure us.
If you can imagine that if assault weapons
were banned, which was the discussion in 1995
when Wayne LaPierre wrote that we saw during
the Barack Obama presidency, the NRA, other
gun groups, activists fear mongering, that
Barack Obama, the scary half black, possibly
Muslim foreign guy, was going to come and
take everybody's guns.
He was going to confiscate all the guns.
And it was a true liberal boogeyman.
And in reality, Barack Obama presided over
one of the largest expansions in gun ownership,
a boon for gun sales that we have seen in
American history because of that fear mongering.
And now the NRA is silent.
The NRA is silent that maybe George Floyd
should have had a weapon to defend himself,
as they sometimes like to say about people
in various sticky situations, as maybe the
term is the NRA completely silent about the
repression of protests and police brutality
and support and encouragement of that brutality
from the president.
And for many of his Republican colleagues.
And yet, when state governments were saying
wear a mask two months ago, that was supposedly
tyrannical repression by the government, which
had the gun people out in force at state capitals
and on city streets.
The reality, of course, is that the NRA and
these other groups believe the Second Amendment
is fundamentally a defense against liberals.
That's really what you need guns for, to defend
yourself against liberals and fake liberal
bogeymen.
The NRA doesn't really care about gun rights
or tyranny.
They care about selling guns and funneling
money to Republicans.
And it would be very problematic for the NRA
to say at this point, listen, don't we need
people to take up guns to protect ourselves
from the militarized, tyrannical poret police
in riot gear?
It would be terrible for optics if they said
that it would put them at odds with the establishment.
It would be seen as encouraging violence.
And when they talk about defending the gun
rights of law abiding citizens, the idea in
their heads is of a white conservative man.
Now, of course, look, listen.
I've been around enough to know they include
carefully selected safe instances of defending
the gun rights of soccer moms with a handgun
in their purse and, you know, picking out
some black folks to hold up as look here,
here's some examples.
But the silence that we're seeing in light
of the recent protests and repression by police
surprises nobody who's been paying attention.
Remember Phil Landow, Castiel, Phil Landow,
Castiel was a black man who legally owned
a gun, did exactly as instructed by police,
was calm, complied, and he was killed without
real consequences for the officers involved.
Where was the NRA?
And after the fact, the NRA came up with this
sort of post hoc rationalization from their
spokeswoman, Dana.
Loesch, I don't know if Dana Loesch is still
a spokeswoman.
She was at the time and she said, well, the
reason we're not coming to the defense of
Phil Landow casts the illegal gun owner who
did exactly what police asked and was still
killed, happened to be black.
Is he not only had a firearm, he was in possession
of a controlled substance at the same time
he had drugs on him.
And that's illegal.
And that's how the NRA was able to say who?
We don't have to go out there and defend the
Castiel because he had drugs on him.
Right.
That must have been what it was.
And before I forget, the NRA also exists.
I alluded to this before to funnel dark money
to Republicans through political advertising.
We saw that in 2016 with the Trump campaign.
They at the NRA helped Trump get elected by
funneling shadowy money directly into pro
Trump campaign online advertising campaigns,
investigations into that were started.
They were attempted.
They didn't go very far.
I think you won't be shocked to hear so again,
back when it was protests, because the government
wants us to stay home and wear masks when
we're out.
They brought their guns out.
And I was thinking that this is the government
tyranny, public health guidelines like mask
wearing and holding off on haircuts for the
time being.
This is the government tyranny.
And then now, as we see heavily militant militarized
police forces come out in response to protests
about government.
Right.
I mean, when we talk about police using force
and killing people, that is government over
using force, the government might become tyrannical.
People are missing their gun.
And in fact, they're criticizing the protesters.
So never, ever, ever, ever again.
If you ever fell for it to begin with, should
you fall for any of these talking points?
We need guns because the government might
become tyrannical.
We support.
We always come out in support of people who
have been victimized by actors, elements of
government and longed for it.
It's that's not what it's ever been about.
It's about selling guns.
It's about defending primarily their main
constituents, which are conservative white
men, with exceptions, of course.
And as a funnel conduit for getting money
to Republican politicians, that's what they
exist for.
And they're proving it every single day.